greetings from podcast Ville its July
15th the day the devil was buried at
[ __ ] see the Churchill what's
happening now is brought to you by zip
recruiter listen you know how hard it is
to find intelligent hard-working people
out there you know how hard it is to
find qualified candidates you have any
idea it takes a long time all right
too many applicants you got to go
through them ba bla bla bla bla bla
zip recruiter makes all that go away you
know why cuz zip recruiter makes it easy
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employees who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through this site ready for this one
within the first day no more weeks three
weeks to find now that's how effective
use the zip recruiter is so do me a
favor right now to the church family
you could try zip recruiter for free you
could try it for free for free that's
what I'm coming at you out of Monday
morning for free when you use this
exclusive address ready grab a pen zip
recruiters comm slash church zip
recruiting coms last Church it's that
easy
no more zip recruiter will send your job
to over a hundred of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there you
understand me and like I said right now
you try it for free that zip recruiter
comm slash Church CH you are CH zip
recruiter the smartest way for you to
hire number to the church is also
brought to you by on it listen when it
comes to supplements on it is the way to
go I get on planes every two weeks I pop
two or three of those shroom techs
immunes nothing and I'm sitting next to
far and is they got turbans on you know
what I'm talking about flip-flops [ __ ]
like that no big deal Here I am tip-top
Magoo it keeps your immune system it
doesn't end there if you're not focused
and they got out for brain who else
gives you a hundred percent money-back
guarantee and they don't want the
product back cool good I'll wait nobody
on it so when you have a car guarantee
like that
I have to do business with you I
guarantee nobody around
each Ranch Dressing either that's why I
do business room and I suggest you do
the same so go to Ana calm right now
take a look at the supplements I can't
help you with the kettlebells in the
club bats and whatnot
but as far as supplements are concerned
uncle Joey's got you gonna calm right
now press in church CH you are CH and
get 10% off with the vitamins delivered
right the house kick this [ __ ]
muley thank you very much for tuning in
to our weekly [ __ ] show here
it's Joey Diaz and the [ __ ]
coming out here today direct it's a slow
Monday we got another podcast coming up
this week up all the podcast boy your
favorite we get on on here with you
today and keep in touch with your
[ __ ] and make sure you're
tip-top Magoo I want to thank everybody
came out to the Charlotte shows they
were [ __ ] tremendous I mean you know
just great audiences from Thursday the
Friday and Saturday you guys were great
so [ __ ] tap yourselves on the back
for coming out we had a great time I had
a great time I want to thank Brad laning
and Mike for opening up for me great
[ __ ] show and that's it and that's
that you know it's funny we do you know
two of these a week [ __ ] eight to ten
of these a month and listen my
philosophy is this we reach out we do
the best we can and pieces fall where
the [ __ ] they may I can't if I come here
and I know I did the best I can and
whatever we made your laugh but we
touched on a subject we do that job okay
I don't know how the podcasts are gonna
be and I don't know how you receive them
and to be honest yeah it's something
that you never know you could have Jesus
Christ on hand not hear a thing and then
do a podcast about frustration and
people hitting you up with [ __ ]
emails so I never know I never know what
to expect all I know is I come in here
and we try to [ __ ] talk things over
and that's it and that's that I wasn't
[ __ ] around Isis in your
neighborhoods and just saw him [ __ ]
driving around before if you don't have
your paperwork correct staying mind your
business listen I'm in this country 153
years and I'm [ __ ] walking around on
eggshells today so
not too happy in your last name hey you
don't trade your last name yeah look
behind you you don't see me [ __ ]
speeding today nothing nothing I don't
jaywalk today for the whole week ain't
doing nothing I'm minding my business I
might not even even go over lore okay
one minute I'm driving next one I'm
gonna [ __ ] hunt in Texas with 50
Mexicans with masks on and [ __ ] smelling
like [ __ ] that's poor [ __ ] place
Jesus Christ
what am I will you they just said just
let him out give him rollerskates make
him go downhill you got a thousand
[ __ ] Mexicans and Mitch with
watermelons and Cubans and God knows
what else is in that [ __ ] cage
sweating off that it got no t-shirt on
their [ __ ] thesis is around Jesus
Christ well [ __ ]
feces [ __ ] all over the place [ __ ]
bird [ __ ] just get the door point him in
the right direction get made bucks tell
them if they come back they're gonna end
up in Sing Sing and let him go that's
worse punishment than [ __ ] keeping
them in there breathing their own
[ __ ] Mexican shitty peanuts whatever
the [ __ ] they got in there no telemundo
and you imagine being in there no hablo
no nowhere to sit [ __ ] it's amazing
what's going on in this country today by
the way who gives a [ __ ] about that the
real issues are us right now and how we
cope with things it's funny I was
talking about frustration you know how
we all get frustrated with ourselves and
you know listen first you start
frustrated frustration on the system or
whatever you're lashing out on your boss
or your job and then you total
frustration on yourself and it just
grows okay so now you get out of the
frustration zone you have a long talk
with yourself you write down what you
need to do to change and you put your
plan into action now what's next you got
expectations you know this weekend in
Charlotte
I learned something I learned that my
last year I executed how I want to I
stuck to my plan and now I'm seeing the
results in Charlotte I did five shows
and each show was better than the last
one you and you know I'm honest with you
guys I tell you what like when I went to
New Orleans I ain't a bag of [ __ ] in
Columbus I had good show
but in Charlotte for some reason another
my energy was right on the execution the
material was right on
I even got to improvise the beginning a
couple shows just had some people that I
grew up with in the audience and I
wanted to explain to them you know how I
incorporate all that into my act and
whatnot I talked about the number one
bus and growing up with the [ __ ]
junkies and all this [ __ ] but my point
is this you know last year I got the
opportunity to shoot a Netflix special
and you guys were very happy and you
guys were very supportive and I tried to
work as hard as I thought I could work
but I did it all wrong I put different
pressures on me from different direction
that weren't necessary but that's not
hero they're the most important thing
was what I did about you know when I got
on that plane like I've said a thousand
times when you see these guys lose and
MMA and they're sitting on the mat and
they're like well he got knocked out why
isn't he getting up he's fine he's
hearing a couple birds and [ __ ] and his
vision is a little [ __ ] up he's
thinking about the things that he did
wrong that's what that flight was for me
tonight after I shot that Netflix
special and I want to thank in that
place for give me the opportunity
everything I just didn't prepare for it
the right way mentally and I [ __ ]
myself that's it then it happens in life
even after 27 year market comedy or the
26 year mark when I was at that time I
[ __ ] myself and that's why we live and
we learn
you're never gonna stop learning if you
live every [ __ ] that if you go for it
you're not gonna learn but if you live
even if you fail you're gonna learn and
then you can either give up or build
yourself up and attack that thing that
you had and that's exactly what I did I
came back and I knew the plan I knew
that the new plan was gonna be I was
gonna try to write one line every day
one line and number two I was going to
try and just perform at The Comedy Store
for some reason I had put a fear of
myself about going down to the Comedy
Store not trying new material I that was
all [ __ ] those were excuses I just
gave myself at every level in our lives
you give ourself excuses
it takes things to smack us to get away
from those excuses so the last year and
you could ask me you're gonna have
something buddy I pretty much staying at
the store I think I've done three maybe
four spots outside the store when I'm in
LA the store is my [ __ ] grounded when
I'm in New York yeah you guys would love
to see me at the cellar and if I go to
the [ __ ] Dangerfield's why because
it's the bottom of the [ __ ] barrel
it's the original room
it's 810 people and you got to work from
a different perspective
you can't work from the perspective ease
of your strength you have to work from
the perspective of your weakness but
anyway when I came back I set a plan in
motion you know I said the same plan up
when I really really ated that that
Netflix performance and what happened
how I led up to it it awesome made me
real value eight the podcast and we
stopped with the marijuana and we
stopped at the edibles
it made me reevaluate where I was
slipping in a lot of areas and we
executed it I stuck to it I'm only going
to the store I only want to follow
daliyah I only want to follow Ali Wong I
only want to follow Sebastian I only
want to follow Bill burr I only want to
follow Ron White and I only want to
follow Joe Rogan that's it plain and
simple lately I've been following Theo
that's exactly where I like that's even
better for me a change in energy
somebody with a draw you know these are
the things I forced myself to do do you
know how many nights I'm sitting on my
couch at 8:30 and I gotta go do a spot
it's [ __ ] 10 o'clock and I gotta
follow three heaters you know what it
takes for me to put my [ __ ] shoes on
those nights and you know me I don't
just put my shoes on I take a whole
[ __ ] shower and while I'm in the
shower I'm actually getting into
character preparing to go to the [ __ ]
store preparing like that's how
seriously I take the store after 22
years when I go down there it's to go to
[ __ ] war it's like going old Jackson
Winkeljohn it's like going on America's
top teen you've been [ __ ] around in
your garage for years
you got it served you a purpose to a
certain level now you have to force
yourself into that [ __ ] level part of
your expectations is forcing yourself
it's not what you want to do what you
believe in
it's forcing yourself you know flying
[ __ ] sucks
flying sucks on every [ __ ] level it's
whatever hours of your time going into
the unexpected what's the unexpected the
plane to go down they might lose your
luggage they don't have a part your
flights [ __ ] delayed you know what I
love doing comedy so much I overcome
that like it doesn't apply to me when I
get on a plane I go [ __ ] prepared I
bring all my [ __ ] so I'm not not one
point do I think about what's going on
right now I'm on a [ __ ] tube that's
closed and I'm flying through the air at
40,000 [ __ ] feet which is pretty
goddamn scary I don't like doing that
but you do it you force yourself to do
the things you don't want to do it's
very easy for me to get in my car and
drive to monster flappers but on the way
back stop and get a [ __ ] doughnut and
it's even easier for me to go to the
[ __ ] haha guys guess what it's even
easier for me to go to the [ __ ] Laugh
Factory cuz all I really got to do is
[ __ ] go down the hill hooker [ __ ]
left hooker right and I'm right in front
on a Laugh Factory I pull up I get the
world valet ten bucks and I tell them
I'll be out in 15 minutes and still I
refuse to go at any of these places not
because they're bad places not because I
don't like to manage when I don't like
the club
I love the [ __ ] him props the Improv
made me who I am
workwise I work what twenty weeks a year
in a [ __ ] improv but my work out my
home my true soul where I get to be a
[ __ ] animal and nobody says a word to
me about it is the Comedy Store
so that's how I wanted to Train when I
go to the Comedy Store I go to the
Comedy Store to be [ __ ]
animal when you guys go to like when I
used to roof for example I worked for a
company from Monday to Friday and we did
flat roof anybody knows anything about
what I'm talking about
this probably roofers listen to me right
now we did flat roofs and we specialize
in ballasted roofs which roofs would
have made from rubber and then you put
rock on them to hold them down
you have to fledge oh you know you have
to flash all the the pipes and the
[ __ ] air conditioners and heaters and
all that [ __ ] but basically you lay the
[ __ ] thing down you put the rubber
you put rock on top on the weekends I
would go to neighborhoods I would
because in Colorado it always hails I
had a wife I had a kid and I think at
the time as a roofer when I started I
made six hundred bucks a week I was
making fifteen bucks an hour whatever
times 40 hours a week whatever that is
you know at 600 at 600 a week I was
making 600 a week that's 2,400 a month
they were paying me cash
so basically making 2,400 a month so the
supplement my income I would roof on the
weekends and I would roof residential
homes you know a garage with a [ __ ]
house of extension now most people look
at those houses and regular roofing
company would look at those houses and
say that would if I bid it and I did it
it would take me four days well guess
what me and another guy would do those
houses in two days we would go up in a
[ __ ] Saturday tear off the existing
roof [ __ ] take all the nails out
clean the [ __ ] wood put the [ __ ]
new rubber on it leave it overnight then
the next day come back and put all the
shingles on that I don't know how many
[ __ ] square feet and how many
packages of shingles they were I can't
remember now but I know between me and
him it was a lot more than what a whole
[ __ ] company would do with four guys
in four days okay when I was doing the
rubber roof
we were doing 40 square yards a day and
we were tearing up also we were tearing
up at 32,000 year [ __ ] double black
tar roof if you're in the business I
don't have to tell you how heavy that is
we would cut it into [ __ ] with a a
sawed into the into the roof into like
five by five pieces and two guys that
pick him up and put him on a cart and
another guy will pull the carts to the
edge of the roof and throw him off it
was [ __ ] tremendous I was in the best
day of my life we would do forty squares
a day that was my brother-in-law and the
reason why I heal 42 some people you
like Joey how many people would you have
on this crew we had five [ __ ]
on this crew that's a lot of work every
day for [ __ ] faut it for five guys
but if you know anything about my
brother-in-law and how good of a worker
and the roofie he was we could have
probably done 660 squares a day with one
extra guy if you would have let him but
yeah you have to space out the jobs you
have to space out the jobs unless you're
that busy he wasn't that busy it was a
one-year commitment on his roof so we
said [ __ ] it we'll uh wolf [ __ ] you
know take our time on the roof my point
is that on the weekends I could have
done those rules in four days I did him
in two I went down to work I knew that I
had to finish this by Sunday at seven
o'clock for us to get a check because we
had regular jobs on [ __ ] Monday we
had regular jobs on Monday night o'clock
so what I'm trying to say to you is when
I went on these jobs on Friday on
Saturdays and Sundays I was a [ __ ]
animal we would put the radio on and not
even talk to each other there was no
jokes there was no nothing we would eat
on the run like the wall I went down the
stairs and when he would go down the
stairs he would go you hungry yeah bring
up a sandwich we wouldn't even take an
hour for lunch we were [ __ ] animals
and we didn't give a [ __ ] it was a
different games the others time trying
to say
you work for yourself and when you work
for somebody else it's two different
head [ __ ] spaces you'll really learn
what labor is so when I'm on the road
it's a different mentality when I'm at
the store I'm going down there to try
new material mixed with old material and
I got a follow eight [ __ ] killers
when I'm on the road I follow an MC
who's just starting out he may be doing
comedy one to two years and I got a
feature act in front of me that could be
of any denomination he could be a
headliner for all the [ __ ] I know but
when I'm at the family store you see
five headliners in a row before I go up
that's tough work
that's tough work I gotta make sure
those five guys aren't doing something
that I'm doing something in the same
vein plus my job when I go to the comedy
store as much as I don't want to be as
honest about this as I can because I
don't want you guys to think for me it's
a competition but when I go to the
comedy store there's 200 people in the
original room audience and I go there to
do one thing and one thing only that's
my practice I go there to be remembered
I go in there just the same way I go in
there for a comedy showcase I don't go
in there to destroy the rule I go in
there so I stick out from the 12 comics
you about to see that night are you with
me in a way so what I understand like
I'm with the roofing it makes sense like
with it with a full-time job they have
to space it out you they don't want to
kill you when you're doing it on the
weekends you only have two days you want
to get it done I get that why-why-why is
the mindset different and they're doing
a full hour in a club than it is at the
store because at the store they're
paying $15 and they might not even know
I exist
they're coming to see Chris D'Elia so
right so they might go to see Bobby Lee
from MADtv they might go see Halle Wong
from her movie on Netflix when they go
to see you on a weekend as a headliner
they go specifically to see you right so
to me
so to me who has no experience
headlining it to me makes that do you
want to do more like do you want to do
better on the weekend cuz they're coming
for you I want to do good all the
[ __ ] right my world okay at this 28
year marks when I'm doing comedy it's
like The Godfather said I can't men
don't make mistakes women and children
make mistakes men don't make mistakes at
this level I know in my heart there is a
percentage game but at this level I
always want to do the best that I can at
the store when I go on the road I have
to give you twenty eight dollars to
thirty dollars worth of funny ok were
too funny when I go to the comedy store
I go there to be remembered got it
so so do you think me yourself might not
not that wouldn't work but it wouldn't
it wouldn't feel the same as a headliner
if we did what you did at the store I do
what I do it to store for 15 minutes ok
when I'm in a [ __ ] room I'm doing 50
minutes ok so it's two different worlds
okay it's two different comparisons when
I go to the store I take a headline set
and I eliminate all the fat and I just
give you points lines got when I'm at
the club I gotta talk for 15 minutes so
the pacing is different got it
I try to keep that pace up I'll have a
[ __ ] heart attack but I do it the
Comedy Store okay when I go on the
Comedy Store and it's 15 [ __ ] minutes
I go up there to kill that mother
[ __ ] audience I can't just tell you I
go up there to be remembered when I go
to the clowny Club I want you to
remember me but I also want you to say
Jesus Christ
I paid 28 four tickets ten for parking
50 for cocktails 40 for a babysitter and
that was a great [ __ ] show
God well that was a great show I always
wanted to give them a great show when I
opened for Rogan my job or Rogan was for
me to destroy the room that was my job
rogon for me to go up there and do
between 15 and 20 minutes and destroy
the room I had a very good mentor I put
myself around very good people you know
when I was opening up for Paul Mooney he
would tell me to go up there and level
the room most headliners do not want
somebody in there to level the room I
want the guy in there to level the room
I want the feature actor I bring on the
road to level the room whether it's Dean
or [ __ ] you know the skinny chick with
us gonna be [ __ ] Kate Quigley or
[ __ ] you know Simba Matt Voltron
Voltron was Simone I encouraged him to
[ __ ] level the room if not I'd go to
[ __ ] what stop my hoping might that
closed and Hollywood parties I go to
Marty's and take the worst kid and put
him in front of it if I'm gonna look
like a star no I want thinking I in
front of me to shine and I wanted the MC
to [ __ ] shine I want them to get
every dollars worth of a show that's why
I like to travel and bring feature acts
that I know from Hollywood because I
want them to get more value I really
like bringing women with me on the road
because a lot of guys bring dates and
the dates look at like they tell them
all about uncle Joey's crazy and ten
minutes into my set the date doesn't
like me
I want the date to get something out of
this show the girl in front of them was
pretty [ __ ] funny got it I want the
girl to get something out of the show
I just don't want that's why I like
women opening up for me because even if
they don't like me the girls as well
that girl made me laugh got so I mean so
I guess what it would kind of what
you're saying is the whatever happens at
the store before and after you really
doesn't impact you and when you're on
the road it's like you're in charge of
it Richie sure constructed the comedy
short stored afraid to be a lab for
comics
it's a college for comics it's a four
year to seven year program
I just wrote an interesting article in
the LA Weekly it was published maybe
three years ago about the dude who stuck
up for the dude who was hittin Mitzi
who's a great guy shouldn't be
portraying him like this anyway
he always opens up the story he's an old
guy right yeah I forget what his name is
um I know you're talking about and he
was talking about how the Comedy Store
is a for Argos house
yeah they a great guy phenomenal writer
he spoke about how his Comedy Store is a
four to seven year education he's not
lying and that's after you do five years
and your [ __ ] neighborhood comedy
club like it's not just getting on stage
there
it's the watching it's the electricity
it's the feeling the vibe when Mitzi
shore opened up the Comedy Store she
created to be a four to seven year
college in life guys what do you do when
you want to make the most out put on uh
something what do you do you go to the
junior college for a year then you get
into a nice College and then you want to
get your masters or your doctorate or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to get or
your law degree it's another three years
so it's seven years of your life no
matter what you do if you join the
[ __ ] Navy and you wanna fly [ __ ]
jets you still gotta get a college
education then it's another six [ __ ]
years in the Navy before you can fly
[ __ ] jets so that's ten years you
gotta be dabbling around I may be wrong
by two years but I think if you go on as
a college graduate you go on as an
officer so no matter what you pick in
this life you're gonna have to put time
in it and then and when you think about
the time you go oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna do it and double that once
you're there you're enjoying it so much
that you're sitting back and you go I'm
gonna get to that level but for right
now I'm gonna enjoy where I am
that's a hard look that for me that's
the hardest thing about almost anything
no I'm not good at that
that's that's the [ __ ] that will kill
you that you have to look at those guys
like Bill Byrne Sebastian and Ali Wong
and Joe Rogan or the people that you
work with in your field or the top-notch
in your area and go guess what that guy
ain't got dick on me it's just gonna
take me 10 years to catch up that I got
but I will be there and the longer that
I've been in this town no longer I'm
saying what do you think that [ __ ]
deal Vaughn just walked here off the
field off the plantation in [ __ ]
Louisiana do Vaughn's been in LA a long
[ __ ] time checking around MTV this
that bill Vaughn has been kicking it
around two [ __ ] years he just didn't
walk off the [ __ ] you know Katrina
watch you know Bobby Lee has been
walking around as long as I've been
walking around I still remember Bobby
Lee you know coming up from San Diego
man you guys have heard the stories this
is a journey you have to look at it and
go hmm interesting
I'm not there but I will be I will be
what does it require from me to get
there that's where the notebook and
paper are essential where you have to
write down that you want to be where
that do you [ __ ] rip guys I'm a
[ __ ] ex [ __ ] cokehead you guys
know that do you think in my cocaine
stupor if you guys know anything about
cocaine or have you done cocaine or if
you have a relative that does cocaine
named [ __ ] the word patience anywhere
in that addiction
there's no [ __ ] patience in that
addiction that's why you do coke you're
sitting around all day and even through
the cocaine I had enough logic that I
would look at Rogan and go I don't know
if I'm gonna get there like I would open
up for Joe when I was opening up for Joe
from 2000 to 2010 guys for 10 years do
you guys really think that I had my
eyeball on [ __ ] headlining again not
in a million years
Reno is such a lazy sack of [ __ ] that I
was pretty content and just featuring
for Joe people would call me and make me
headline and I'd headline but it wasn't
something I was aspiring to do ten years
ago I was very happy opening up for Joe
Wow
because I didn't listen I didn't go to
Montreal I didn't go here I was never
included than anything all I was doing
was booking movies somebody put a thing
on Facebook the a day I'm one of the
church page is that they can't believe
how much TV I've done over the years and
then now when they see me at tickles
from Lorne on SVU to the meatball king
on the kid show to the I didn't want the
Wizards of Waverly I did [ __ ] you
know cold case I did all those shows on
CBS and I did co-stars on all those
[ __ ] things and people can I'd the
scare tactics has been playing a lot
lately okay and I did four or five did
four or five episodes of scare tactics
maybe they've been playing lately and
people been hitting me oh my god I got
home [ __ ] up the other night I saw you
an episode of scare tactics where you
were they had the cocaine in the cars
and I had to get the cocaine from the
kid it was me no episode I taped the
other night because of the a night I
couldn't sleep and I woke up and the
episode was just about to come on
of me and the guy who shoots Tony
Montana in the bar and Scarface who I
talked about the story that he was an
extra that's how I found out because I
got to work with him on scare tactics he
owned the garage some guy came in for a
job they gave him a job and then he
finds cocaine in the door panel so he
tells the guy for the Scarface while
got from Scarface close to call the cops
I come in with another bodybuilder guy
and I tell the guy it's my coke we're
gonna shoot him
and the kids [ __ ] shake him oh my god
oh they showed the other one when I
wanted to the kid goes but my dead
grandmother on my [ __ ] your dead
grandmother they beep out the [ __ ] your
dead grandmother it's it's ridiculous
and I was thinking about when I was
doing those shows
it had to be 2002 2003 2004 here I was
doing movies TV opening for Joe and I
knew the producers of that show so they
would just call me and say you available
next week yeah we're gonna write a
sketch feed so it would just write
sketches for me I would fly it from
Burbank to Vegas they would shoot they
would shoot on Thursdays I would go from
Burbank to Vegas on Wednesday spend the
night get [ __ ] hammered they would
give me per diem like 65 bucks per diem
hush a goodbye and a half grandma coke
and a pack of cigarettes yeah they
[ __ ] shoot the next day and then they
give me $65 per diem again and then they
used to be a club in Chicago and they
used to I would direct flight from Vegas
to Chicago okay
and I would riddles KJ riddles was the
neighborhood it's closed now but Kenny
still alive and kicking he was good god
bless him riddles used to book me for
800 a weekend for four shows to headline
hello Friday since a finite area Friday
and sadly Wow it was [ __ ] King cuz
across the street was White Castle I'll
[ __ ] next to it was shaken bake I was
taking shakes taking shake although the
[ __ ] it is and then down the block was a
whole town that had a sushi place and
every time you ate the sushi Chicago is
not bueno
you wake up with splinters in your
throat and show my god and monkey shells
and you got a rash but I would destroy
and then there was a cheesecake but
cheese take place okay like those
sausage sandwiches yeah that would
deliver and they were fantastic and I
had week at such a great relationship
with them that I call them as soon as I
landed in the hotel let's take jeez -
take the cheese
deliver a sauce to sandwich you know the
hot beef with the sausage yeah and the
combo got a long I would give them an
extra 20 give me a couple pills and
thousands worth of marijuana and he'd
make me a pipe out of a little phone at
the restaurant oh my god that's how many
times I would go to Chicago to KJ
riddles holy [ __ ] and you were in and at
that point and I was have you seen
yourself doing that for the rest of your
life oh yeah I was that much of a
[ __ ] dead dead piece of [ __ ] like as
long as I did cocaine got a couple of
gigs of rogue and got a couple
headlining gigs here and there from time
to time to make like a the nine hours
for the weekend I'd be happy Wow so you
kinda I mean it was a I guess patient is
in the word you were content but talk
how I got no Paris I lost a little
[ __ ] girl lost a daughter cuz I was a
loser I went to prison where in my
mindset was I prepared for today I never
saw me headlining and people buying
tickets in my life I was lucky enough
just to be included I was content just
being a regular at the store opening up
to Joe doing little spots I was very
content it was never really about the
money at all for me I could look at you
guys and tell you listen there was such
a struggle for years I had given up on
money 20 years ago and I was probably in
those days I was cracking anywhere from
80 to 100 grand a year I would bust out
of 20,000 the whole deal from somebody
and the rest I'd make hacking and doing
stand-up golly and the acting in those
days I was getting 1250 1750 you know
for spider-man I got 600 a day I mean
there was no money when acting for me
everybody else is making all this
exuberant money I was a shitheel I got
scale on everything you know but I
[ __ ] worked so like what what when do
you think being content goes from a good
thing to holding you back do you think
absolutely absolutely we all get in a
comfort zone we all get in a comfort
zone and sometimes life throws you into
the [ __ ] lion's cage you know I love
to you know listen life threw me into
the lion's cage but one day I got out
and I went back into the lion's mouth
full of chair down and sat down I did it
on my tongue like there's two different
ways you'd go on the lion's cage you
could go into the lion's cage on your
terms or on that tux
right we all go into the lion's cage on
that term eventually okay
and then it's our job to get ourselves
out of the lion's cage go back in there
Tyler Lyons shut up sit down open your
mouth I'm putting my [ __ ] dick in
your mouth so you're always gonna be in
the lion's cage it's your job to get out
and then go back there and you can set
the [ __ ] rules right I didn't know
that either I didn't know that you know
I didn't know that either
for years I depended on calm but that's
a lie because in 2002 I was I was doing
my own auditions I was hustling my own
scripts I had taken my hustle it has an
actor to a different [ __ ] level
that's why when you look at my and DB
you see tons of work what and there's
tons of [ __ ] that didn't get reported
tons of [ __ ] but I think about what the
[ __ ] that happens that I credit that's
great
so if you if you want me to take this
out there I it's crazy that we're
talking about this because some I've
been thinking about something and I
think I need to be careful about how I
say it because I don't want I don't want
anyone to think of it I'm ungrateful
because you doing this and meeting us
changed my life but you said something
about a year ago on the podcast that
I've been thinking about you said the
you just offhand
he said lucky in a year or two you won't
be able to do the podcast you're gonna
have to if you want to do common you're
gonna have to go out on the road and and
like the New York trip and San Francisco
really opened my eyes to show me what
was available and I the thing that has
been going through my brain last couple
weeks is am i content
because I'm nowhere near ready to I'm
not gonna make a living being a comic if
I was gonna be on the road I'd be
driving lift and doing post mates and
renting a room for a couple months in a
different City but just were you saying
that a year ago I've been thinking about
it I'm like is it is it now am I
because I am very content and when I do
I do like this I like getting to meet
people getting to do this and and doing
spots around LA but when is that when is
the right time when when do I go into
the law like tigers deadly it's kind of
a this is all decision you have to make
this is what nobody could tell you
nobody could tell you anything one
morning you wake up you two feet hit the
ground you go pee and you say I'm going
for this but I'm now looking back you
know in 1995 I was forced to do
something I never tried to do I never
ever ever ever in my life
dreamt of it I thought I would live in
Boulder Boulder in 1995 was a different
community it was a little smaller there
was no traffic and in my world I coulda
saw myself dying there like I really
could have saw myself pilot but there
was a problem the problem of bold route
I didn't have a college degree so my job
will limit it I had the sports betting
service but I worked for and they gave
me a job and which gave me the
opportunity between us sitting Ava's
family gave me the opportunity there
were guys there making 200,000 a year
and taking the summer off and then like
early 90s early nineties there were guys
making 200,000 that office and quitting
on April 15 and having May June July off
and coming
like August 15 [ __ ] I'm at $200,000 a
year I could see myself do that I just
couldn't see myself Megan to a thousand
a year really yeah like right my
thinking was shot you know like I was a
felon I had all these strikes against me
you know my parents just I had all this
stinking thinking I have all this [ __ ]
there's mental baggage that I was
carrying that would never thought that I
would be one of the top salesmen in
there but to get back to all we were
talking about I knew in Boulder I really
wanted to do comedy I had failed that
everything else or not even failed with
everything else there was nothing else I
really wanted to do when I it took me a
month to make my decision so I had to
leave Boulder because I was going to end
up in jail I was gonna do something
stupid they were gonna force my hand and
I knew it I know me and then life
clothes signs at you you know I'm
writing that book right now and it's
like the Sacred Heart School for Boys I
went to was an orphanage the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] Street we moved on given that
Terrace before was given a terrorist was
given that orphanage and it [ __ ]
burned down we live close to a cemetery
you know the girl telling me her mother
died in the eighth grade
all these things were assigned to me
that I was going to lose somebody very
special to me I was always around death
you know and I didn't see the signs
because I was a youngster and I didn't
like thinking about that you know but in
life life gives you signs the first
[ __ ] sign I had was April of 95 well
it was I got thrown out of the [ __ ]
comedy works I got banned and then maybe
you know a month after that maybe like
March was when I smacked John in the
face
and I saw my little girl crying in the
car and I got in the car and I and I it
made me feel good about why was but I
saw what I didn't want from my daughter
you know at that time I didn't wanted to
grow up like me and anger and fighting
with parents I didn't want that so that
was the first sign the second sign was
getting thrown out of the economy works
and then the third sign was I met a girl
I went on the road I met a girl and she
was going to see how and there was
something about me that I always wanted
to go to Seattle and do Connolly I don't
know what it was
what's Sean I asked her where she was
moving I wanted her to say Seattle and
she said Seattle and I almost [ __ ] my
pants number three there was there were
three signs and then I went into the
reality of it the reality was I was a
[ __ ] loser and County was the only
thing I could do and if I stayed there
nothing good was gonna happen yeah I
might have ended up a local comic and
maybe I would opened up for the Denver
Nuggets and maybe they could have been a
lot of options but I didn't see any of
them
I saw no future trying to do what I
loved and being at war with somebody at
the same time right I got in my [ __ ]
car and it was still the hardest drive
of my life I was leaving a place that I
lived there for 13 years it was a huge
part of my childhood I had grown up
there I had gone to prison there I got
married there there was so much of an
emotional attachment to me being there
but at the same time I really wanted to
pursue this I didn't want to pursue
stardom I didn't want to pursue
Hollywood I just wanted to let me know
so I could stick with something and I
could be a productive member of society
what's a productive member of society a
guy that makes 40,000 a year pays taxes
and doesn't get in trouble that's all I
wanted and I thought that Carly could
get me out of trouble it pulled me out
of Bowl
well I sit here across from you and I
tell you that I've been on a boulder for
24 years and that I cannot ever believe
I found the strength to left Boulder to
leave bold I could use New Jersey
comparison in like 83 but Who am I
kidding
I was forced to leave I forced myself to
leave Boulder was where you are right
now when you called me from New York
what I said to you having a good time
and like are you seeing our normal
people live right you're seeing how you
should be living don't worry about the
money it all happens they'll come to you
that this is how you should be living
you shouldn't be talking the Joe Diaz or
Steve Simone or these guys because
there's nothing they could do for you
but ruin you you have to talk to people
who are your age and going through what
you're going through when you're at
these [ __ ] places birds and these
places you're talking to people who are
trying to be movie stars right they're
not trying to be down and dirty
comedians they don't want to learn the
mechanics of tablet they're trying to
cut you and I'm not saying all those
people no no that's very well here forty
percent of those people are trying to
cut through to the fast track to get to
a place I came from a place when nobody
spoke about that all we focused on was
on stand-up comedy right so yeah I
expect you any day to go I've been
thinking about it I want to be a
stand-up comic I need to go to New York
or I need to go to San Francisco and
bang it out with kids my age the natural
evolution is I'm married I have a family
you know I've been here 22 years I have
the Comedy Store
I'm already established as a comic
you're trying to do the same thing this
is a place that you get established here
we've had 15 guests who have done comedy
in LA and established here um I think
for you would be better to go to New
York I also to your mother
New York will be tough just cuz how
expensive it is or my what everybody
says expensive listen every place is
expensive right especially when you're
doing comic but $3,000 could be a lot
what $3,000 could be a little always
remember that that's your choice when
you look at things 3,000 could be a lot
or 3,000 could be a little no you know
if you have to move to [ __ ] Jamaica
Queens and will be yourself into
Manhattan the [ __ ] you know or
whatever the [ __ ] however you want to do
it over and then park your car and then
take the train you'll figure it out when
you want to do something that bad
that you really really want to do this
you'll figure it out
right you'll figure it out you know
everybody has that time in their life
when they have fully you know and it
doesn't work forever there's people who
are very close with their families and I
appreciate that and I understand that I
know where you come from but there's
other people who have a dream and it's
uncontrollable and they want to go for
it whether it be a dance for Vegas
whether it beats doing theater in New
York whether it be doing theater in
Chicago you know me I wouldn't want to
be in this market for stand-up when I'm
starting at all right and I'm much
unnecessary chatter that you need to
hear and even even without that the
thing that I noticed because I'm very
lucky for the level that I'm at I've got
to do great shows that most people don't
but it's still limited because there's
so many amazing comics here the the
shows that I got to do in those two
cities are about I did about a month's
worth of shows in a weekend and so what
what my thought process was because like
what you were saying about being I this
has been so important and special to me
that I never want to leave here having
any issue with you with the Charlie that
would never be that's that's what I'm
trying to avoid but like what I would do
it I've also only I'm 31
I'm gonna be 31 and I've only really
seen Boston in LA and being in those two
cities showed me how much more there is
and you've talked about like Texas I've
like what if I spent a year in Texas
what if I spent six months in Denver
what if I went to st. Louis and spent
three months you know I went to New York
to do the film and I saw two people in
New York that I was very happy to see
and I let them know it I let them know
it to their face and why and that was
Bob biggest ad and the girl I can't
think of her name right now that's very
funny I did comedy both with those guys
20 years ago in Houston and they got
really stuck and I'm not saying nothing
negative about Houston oh it was a good
comedy scene it was a great comedy scene
but a certain negativity went over the
scene and Bob bigger staff decided to
pick up and go to New York I cannot tell
you how happy I am through and if
anybody knows Bob let him know I can't
believe how proud I am because I know
how tough of a decision it is to pick up
and leave I know it but and there is
never a mistake always remember that
there's never a mistake you left for a
[ __ ] reason there's never a mistake
you don't you make it work because you
dream overpowers the mistake it's never
a mistake I could look you on the eye
and tell you when I went to Aspen the
first time it wasn't a mistake when I
went to Denver the second time Boulder
wasn't a mistake when I left Boulder for
Seattle Jesus Christ you've heard the
stories here wasn't a mistake and when I
left Seattle for LA even though even
though I was not prepared even though I
was not prepared for my journey that way
I know in my heart that a year mark I'd
put my time it I'd really really really
put my time
but do I look back any those I'm [ __ ]
the static that I went and either I made
it work when I went to Seattle I went
with a girl I was broke but guess what
[ __ ] no matter how broke I was I still
got on stage six times the first week
and I got to Seattle on a Saturday and
by Friday I had my first paid gig well I
let it be known that I was there Monday
at that open mic and I went back there
Tuesday and let it be known again and
that thursday i got a call from John Fox
offered me Moscow Idaho with Vince
Valenzuela
I still remember him he's still my buddy
on Facebook and me and Vince drove to
Moscow I know and did Friday and
Saturday that's how you a change of
scenery invigorates you you know it just
does something to you was I I have
nothing but admiration for the Denver
scene that I left the comedy scene there
was nothing wrong when I left Denver
because of personal reasons I left
Denver because I couldn't cope with a
[ __ ] divorce but I knew exactly what
my head was comedy wise so when you get
up when you're ready to [ __ ] make the
move
there is no looking back there is no
windshield wiper
there's no feds following you you make
sure there's no ghosts following you you
put your head down you served your time
you did what you had to do when you go
I'm not I would never be mad at you that
no but no these people would be mad at
you nothing because you're making a move
to better yourself okay you know we've
always discussed it here Leigh you live
like a power thing yeah you're here and
you go to your apartment and you drive a
mile to the fourth wall I've told you
for years that I live in a [ __ ] jail
I live in a four block radius
I go to a gym I go to a coffee shop I go
to cry out I go to a wig store and I go
to jujitsu and kickboxing and I'm back
home every once in a while I go to eat
to get something for breakfast but I
live in a prison also
when I went to New York this year it
opened my eyes a lot of levels it opened
my eyes on things I wanted to do and
didn't want to do blitz but I'm here
right now I can't think for me I have to
think about a family right so I just
can't pick up and leave to go to New
York because they're shooting film in
New York now you know it's all in front
of mine today it's busy as hell on the
East Coast right now I understand but I
can't call home and just take my
daughter out of a schedule because of me
I have to think of three people you were
you're single you're 30 you got the
world by the balls it's time to look
down and venture or stay here and make
the best of your time no matter what you
decide on if you really want to be
economic it's time to downsize take a
look at your possessions and say this is
what I want to do for the next five
years it's a five-year plan and in those
five years I'm gonna hit every state
except Hawaii and [ __ ] Alaska right
but I'm gonna hit every [ __ ] state
and if I got a do temp work in Idaho
I'll do 10 pork if I gotta stop in Texas
and get on a ship for 30 days I'm gonna
ship for 30 days and then load barges if
it makes my comedy career that much
easier down the line I'll do I did
everything I sold insurance on the phone
I thought them did industrial
commercials for AT&T whatever made my
dream possible
I delivered Chinese food I sold coke
well I delivered Chinese food I did
construction you know whatever you have
to do to get your dream going that's
what makes those jobs easier that this
isn't what you want to do all your life
what about the guy that you're making
sandwiches with that subway this is his
life you know that you're doing it for
six months and in the Bronx but in six
months I'm gonna be doing all these
little gigs around the five barrels I'm
gonna be picking up 50 bucks don't give
yourself an unrealistic goal and go I'm
gonna be at the comedy show every night
right when Lewis CK that that's why I
was because I loved New York but that's
why I was like you know what maybe in
maybe New York's a couple years away
just be
because I can see how competitive it is
and I love doing all the spots but I the
only person who paid me in New York was
Louis gave me a couple bucks for the
each set and Philippe out of just out of
the kindness of his heart he didn't have
to so yeah so like I said yes right
that's not so like I was thinking like a
of the all the other places and just uh
really really letting my comedy grow
like I felt like it would give me
opportunity to have new experiences to
draw on and and know I'd be when you go
to a camp you get so good was it when I
would go to a basketball camp for a week
or football camp for a week or you go to
a math camp for a week you really make a
huge improvement because you're thinking
about it for 24 hours like oh there's
nothing else that's all you're thinking
about
I didn't like my experience in New York
in 93 I didn't take full potential of my
Comley experience but the experience I
did take it well I did do I wasn't very
happy with I really wasn't happy with
just because I didn't get the most of it
but I knew I wasn't gonna get the most
out of me it was I don't like to say the
word competitive it was just tough it
was tough you have to bring people you
gotta meet people you got to know people
you got to get up to Brooklyn and you
got to get up to Queens you got to get
up to Long Island you got to go to where
the action is the first two or three
years and I had too much stuff going on
I had a divorce going on you know I had
a lot of [ __ ] on my plate at the time
right so it wasn't gonna work for me I
had to be hands-on I wanted to be a dad
that all [ __ ] up and I [ __ ] that up
but the main point being that's what New
York is when you want to be a good
college
our biggest example for me is Bill birth
he was here but my father show went down
he went to New York he put his head down
and he started at Dangerfield and that
was you know a three-year or five-year
plan you know this is a five-year plan
when you join the service you join for
how long I
for four years I think it's - now you
have a mandatory option into it I think
you have an option to get out after two
but it's four years everything you look
at it's four or five six years so you
have to look at it put your head down
make the best of your time and know that
you're putting in the work every day so
there's no frustrations and you got to
keep your expectations in the check I
can't say these of the year I'm gonna be
performing in the main room every
people's expectations are [ __ ] out of
their minds
right and then they put their
expectations so high that when they
don't hit them they quit altogether now
you quit altogether no your expectations
should be small you should have goals
you should hit all your goals every week
every week is the same every week is the
same when I was in Denver I had a
schedule Monday the Australian bar and
[ __ ] whatever that thing was close to
Wyoming Tuesday was the Comedy Works
Wednesday was club 56 and Club 52
Thursday was El Torito Friday was a
guest spot it was a two-hour [ __ ]
drive but it was a guest spot and Sunday
was a [ __ ] barn eight o'clock that
followed a dime dancing class in Arvada
Colorado and that's what it was not even
miss it for anything I didn't miss it
for anything
I snorted coke yeah when I finish there
oh yeah I did more drugs than [ __ ]
Whoopi Goldberg but that I did I stuck
there every day if you ask me what I do
every week today I do the same [ __ ]
every week Monday I left Tuesday a box
Wednesday more time Thursday I left
Friday at jujitsu satellite take-off
with the family Sunday I go to open math
you know I write every day and he dad I
don't have to be somewhere at 12 I'm at
the coffee shop at 9:00 writing why
because it's a discipline to discipline
you got to get out it's a discipline you
can write yeah but I can write in my
house you're not gonna write in your
house you've got to get out
you gotta get out to invest that time
you know all these things are a
discipline this is what you are your own
personal CEO everybody wants to be a CEO
you're the CEO of you you're the CEO of
you does the CEO do the same [ __ ] every
day at 5:00 that guy's got a
multi-million company at 5:00 every day
he's at the [ __ ] gym you know what
does that take he's in bed every night
at 10:00
he doesn't care sure he's gonna suck his
dick he doesn't care Tony's gonna [ __ ]
him in the ass he doesn't care if the
Boston Celtics the planche he doesn't
give a [ __ ] of New England his plan he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if it's his mother's
his wife's mother's birthday
he's a better dad if nothing changes
nothing changes it's the same [ __ ] until
you get to that destination then once
you get for that destination you rewrite
it okay I don't need to do this anymore
but I still need to do that it's a
constant evaluation and that's why
expectations should be attainable just
like gold and if you do the work you'll
attain them and you won't get [ __ ]
frustrated and that's the formula for
the [ __ ] week this week like I said
this week we have a another podcast on
Wednesday and Thursday we didn't need to
do this podcast and I could hold you off
to the Wednesday but no I do the same
[ __ ] every [ __ ] week then like that
there's no misunderstandings when you
sell [ __ ] on the phone whether it's
insurance or stocks or bonds you have a
script okay I'll leave you with this you
have a script you get comfortable with
the script and you become the sales in a
month and then one day you go you know
what I got smart I'm not gonna use the
script no more and you don't use the
script anymore can you your sales go
down and you go what the [ __ ] that I do
why my sales going now because you went
off script your life has a [ __ ]
script from Monday this Sunday you
should have a script and it shadow you
know what I know it's boring I know you
really don't like doing it
but it's the same [ __ ] every week for
you to look up and go in five years I'm
gonna be where that guy is this is what
you need to do in five years and that's
what you probably won't be where that
guy is in five years that's the joke but
then you're really waiting though I'll
be there in three years and I'm gonna
continue doing what I'm doing just a
little [ __ ] harder and that's it and
that's that [ __ ] okay
do not forget July 27th I'm doing the
working out with uncle Joey at the ice
house and then August 9th I'm at the
Lincoln Theatre in Washington DC there's
still a couple tickets left the Borgata
on the 10th is also that I'm only doing
one show cuz I got a bunch of family
coming down real quick before yeah
before I get out of your [ __ ] hair I
want to thank our sponsors number one
being on it been there for us
thus [ __ ] close to 660 [ __ ]
episodes on it why because I believed in
them as much as they believed in me when
it comes to hundred supplements they're
as good as gold in my house whether it's
a protein powder whether it's the oil
that you put in the coffee my wife's
been using it for her joints the [ __ ]
shrimp export the shroom tech immune or
the alpha brain I'll Bank my [ __ ]
soul on those things they work they're
effective and half a brain arm or better
yet on it gives you a hundred percent
money-back guarantee and they don't want
the product back if you don't like alpha
brain who else does that in an industry
nobody [ __ ] so go to Hana calm right
now take a look at the great supplements
that they have I'm sorry I can't do
anything for you
under working outside the vest or the
kettlebells or the club backs of bells
whatever the [ __ ] you call them but as
far as supplements I got you
whether it's a turkey jerky the CMT oil
or the shrimp export on the moon I got
you to do me a favor go to Hana calm
right now when you're checking out press
in church CH you are CH and you're 10%
delivered right to La Casa number two I
want to thank separately it's hard out
there hiring people you
and I both know it hiring is challenging
but there's one place you could go while
hiring is simple fast and smart a place
with grown businesses connect connect
qualified candidates that place is zip
recruiter com
listen hiring used to be hard multiple
job sites stacks a resumes confusing
review process
but today hiring is nice and easy when
you go to recruit accom slash church zip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply
your job as applicants come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never grist miss a great match zip
recruiter is so effective you ready for
this one that four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the
first day you know what that means
time and you know what time is money
whether your business is small medium
large zip recruit accom is for you so
what I'm gonna do is this for the church
family
you could try zip recruiter for free
Joey what are you talking about free are
you serious free you can try zip
recruiter by going to zip recruiter Tom
slash Church that CH you are CH that zip
recruiter comm slash Church that CH you
are CH zip recruiter com the smart way
to hi okay I want to thank the zip
recruiter I want to thank on it but most
importantly I want to thank you [ __ ]
savages so having our back always and
forever I'll see you guys here Thursday
morning
tip top [ __ ] Magoo we're ready
to go and don't forget the 27th at the
ice house on a Saturday night 7:30
zip zip be in and out of there
and then all I got left is August 9th at
the Lincoln Theater in DC I'll see you
[ __ ] there stay black have a
phenomenal week and I'll see you guys
Thursday morning love you